I'm gonna teach you an easy way to learn
how to juggle you always see people
starting off juggling three balls
crucial thing to learn is that it's
really only a two ball action and so
what you want to practice first is just
practice catching in the hand while
releasing in the same in just like that
the other thing that you just do that
you do that you do that until you get
bored like when I was 9 years old and I
did that for hours and hours and hours
pretty soon you bring the other ball in
and it's the same motion again it just
keeps on going and then everything from
that is just the variation if as long as
it's with three balls
and that's juggling so once you learn to
juggle just about any three objects
start to look really cool to try to Joe
and I can remember when I was 10 or 11
my mom used to have these little wax
apples decorative apples and like on
that kitchen table and I used to really
like to juggle those and put a lot of
fence in them and they were wax but one
thing you couldn't do with the apples
that I'll try to do right now is take a
bite out of one while you're juggling
[Music]
got to figure out what I'm gonna do then
[Music]